when I was seven years old I murdered
the tooth fairy and this is that story
the year was 2001 and I had just lost my
first tooth I was one of the first
people in my class to lose a tooth so it
was a really big deal everyone was very
impressed as I held my tooth up proudly
for them to see I imagine that's
probably what Beyonce feels like when
she points her microphone to the crowd
when I got home from school that day
I showed my mom and my siblings my tooth
that is when my mom sat me down and told
me all about this elusive tooth fairy
tonight I was going to put my tooth
under my pillow go to sleep and then a
tiny fairy was going to sneak into my
house take the tooth and then leave me
money in its place I had a lot of
questions what happens if I'm not asleep
when she comes what if I have to talk to
her does she speak English what language
does she speak she lives in Antarctica
right how many visits does she make a
night what if she can't find my to what
if my head is just too heavy for her
tiny little body to lift up what if she
just forgets to come okay listen I was
already terrified of Santa a man who
left me multiple gifts a year don't even
get me started on the man-sized rabbit
who leaves me chocolate every Easter not
mythical creature but I was also pretty
terrified of my mailman
as you can tell I was a very anxious
child and an equally anxious adult I
hated talking to people I didn't know I
hated talking to people I did know for
that matter I was so shy that my mom
resorted to paying me 25 cents every
time I said hi back to anyone who
greeted me instead of meeting them with
this weird awkward silence back to the
tooth when bedtime finally came I knew
there was no way I was falling asleep
anytime soon
since apparently I was having company
that night I put on my favorite pajamas
and I brushed my hair before I went to
bed I wanted the Tooth Fairy to think I
was well dressed and pretty even at 7
years old I was a huge narcissist so
it's the middle of the night and I've
spent hours tossing
turning honestly I wanted nothing more
than to just pass out so I miss her
completely luckily at some point I did
fall asleep cut to the next morning and
something feels off I wasn't sure if it
was still the middle of the night so I
didn't open my eyes right away
one thing I was sure about though there
was something lodged under my back that
hadn't been there when I fell asleep I
shifted my body very slightly from side
to side
whatever was under there was hard yet
soft it was about the size of a small
body a fairy's body oh [ __ ] I was laying
on top of the tooth fairy's dead body
I literally froze in fear before you ask
I don't sleep with any stuffed animals
on my bed this is literally the only
thing it could have been I realized I
must have rolled on top of her while she
was trying to take my tooth oh my god
did she suffocate did I break all her
bones I had no way of knowing but one
thing I did know I had just killed
someone I just killed the woman
responsible for exchanging all the
world's teeth for money as far as I knew
I was the most recent kid on earth to
have lost a tooth everyone in my class
knew my parents knew my siblings knew
there was a tooth trail when the
authorities catch wind of her
disappearance
they're coming for me first I had to get
rid of the evidence I decided that first
and foremost I was gonna need to make it
look like the tooth fairy had shown up I
decided I was going to take my tooth out
from under my pillow and throw it down
the garbage disposal I wasn't allowed to
use the garbage disposal but I figured
the next time my mom turned it on the
evidence would be destroyed forever next
I was gonna steal a dollar out of my
dad's wallet I was gonna take the dollar
and place it under my pillow so that way
when the police showed up I could show
them the dollar they know the Tooth
Fairy had shown up to my house and
they'd move on that left one more
problem for me to deal with how was I
going to dispose of this dead body
without my mom finding out looking back
only now do I realize how truly [ __ ]
up this next train of thought was my
first thought was to throw her body in
my bathroom trashcan and cover her with
toilet paper the more I thought about it
I figured it was just too risky
my mom would definitely see the body so
I scratched it I definitely couldn't
throw her body in the huge trash cans in
our side yard for all I knew our
garbageman were huge snitches this idea
out of the question she was probably too
big to flush down the toilet do I dump
her body in the kitchen trash can my dog
was always snooping around there I
couldn't risk her dropping the two
theories
angle the bloody body at my dad's feet
like she did with the rats and birds she
found in our backyard backyard the
backyard that was it I would bury her in
a shoebox in my backyard just like I did
with my dead hamster caramel makes you
rest in peace I decided I bury her in
the exact same spot as my hamster so
that way for the police I don't know
brought some sort of cadaver sniffing
dog to the house I could assure them
that the only dead body on this property
was that of a hamster alibis baby okay I
think we've got a plan here and store
her in a shoe box in my closet until
sundown in the dead of night I take my
plastic shovel that I used to build
sandcastles at the beach with and I dig
a shallow grave by the fence in my
backyard it was the perfect cover-up to
an accidental crime throughout this
entire planning process I still hadn't
opened my eyes I seriously hadn't moved
a single inch in what felt like an hour
I knew that eventually I had to open my
eyes sit up and put my plan into motion
I had to face the facts look straight
into her cold dead fairy eyes and
finally accept what I had done the clock
says it's 7:00 a.m. so it's definitely
morning at this point I slowly sat up my
heart beginning out of my chest that's
when I realized the thing I had been
laying on this entire time was my own
arm that's right at some point during my
stress fueled slumber my arm had lodged
itself under my back and was now
completely numb from the tips of my
finger to the top of my shoulder
couldn't feel a thing I had been laying
on my own arm for the past hour
while I devised a plan to cover up the
murder of the tooth fairy
I have never been so relieved in my life
to know that one I wasn't a cold-blooded
murderer - I wouldn't have to talk to
the police or any strange adult for that
matter and most importantly 3 my mom
wouldn't be mad at me when you're 7
years old there is nothing scarier than
disappointing your parents looking back
the worst part of this story is that one
I did go to look under my pillow to see
what the Tooth Fairy had left me my
tooth was still sitting there right
where I had left it in a plastic ziplock
bag my parents forgot that I had even
lost a tooth and they never came to swap
it out for money like they were supposed
to so not only was I now moneyless and
exhausted but I was gonna have to go
through a whole nother night of waiting
for the Tooth Fairy to show up thanks
mom and dad
[Music]